see you right here where the decimal
point is at the very bottom see it in
blue and light blue above the eye we're
going to do is we're gonna press second
eye okay so you can see there's your eye
and I'm gonna use the caret key over
here right underneath the clearer so
caret 3 so that's the third power so if
I press ENTER you can see it's giving us
the exact answer negative I so you can
see I cube here is negative I now let's
go ahead and do it to a higher power so
say for example if it was I to the 23rd
power so we've got second I raised to
the 23rd power and before we go ahead
and hit enter on that let's go ahead and
calculate what that would be so I to the
23rd what we can do is we can do this a
couple different ways one way to do it
is I squared to the 11th power so you
power to power you multiply that's I to
the 22nd times one more I that gives you
23 eyes right but I squared we know as
negative one right negative one to an
odd power is a negative and the negative
one times I gives us a negative I so the
answer we should get for I to the 23rd
is negative I let's see if we can verify
that so I'm going to press the second
key I'm going to press I down here at
the bottom and I'm use the caret key I'm
gonna raise it to the 23rd power oops
looks like I type that in already let me
do it again so second I raise the 23rd
power enter and you can see it's giving
us negative I same thing we got here at
the bottom so that's all you have to do
so again just go ahead and use that
second key use the I which is right
above the decimal point and you'll be
able to verify you know what these I
values are two higher powers but it's
good to know how to do it by hand just
like I showed you here by just making it
multiples of two and then whatever you
have left over you can have here let's
just look at one more quick example and
I'll show you another technique so say
for example you wanted to find out
what's I to the let's just say 37th so
another way to do this problem is you
can say well how many times does 4 go
into 37 evenly nine times right with one
left over now we know that I to the
fourth is 1 so this is really just gonna
be 1 times I which is I so this is
another way to do it now if this came
out to I squared then it would be
negative
if the leftover was I cubed then it
would be negative I and then if there's
nothing left over it would just be one
so what you can do is you can use these
values and just cycle through one two
three four you know and so on five six
seven eight but what you do is you
divide by four and then you look at the
left over
okay whatever however many eyes are left
over if there are none left over it's
one okay if there's one left over its I
if there's two left over it's negative
one and if there's three left over
remaining then it's negative I so I hope
you enjoyed this video about how to work
with the ti-84 finding higher powers of
I subscribe to the channel check out
more tutorials on Mario's math tutor and
YouTube channel and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon